مشاهدينا ننتقل الان الى كرمان وكلمه
للرئيس الايراني ابراهيم
رئيسي الخميني ام مكتب عاش وهي تسير على
امتداد مدرسه الامام الحسين شهيد كربلاء
انتم ايها الاسر والعوائل فيرمان عوائل
الشهدا اعلموا ان دماء ابنائكم الذكران
شما
ازواج همار شما
وزملائهم
در مورد وجود مقدس اب
عبدال
زاره خدا حس خون قلبشو داد تا
از
زند ش جامعه
بشده در
عالمون
دئ
وسطها نفرت نسبت به رج صون و امر وهذا ما
يثير
الكراهيه يوما بعد يوم ضد الكيان الصهيوني
وضد الولايات المتحده وهذا ما ايقض الشعوب
في العالم وما تروه من صحوه ويقظه في
العالم هو كله ببركه هذه الدماء الزكيه
للمسلمين التي تراق
ان شا
الله و آنه به شما مردم و عزان مون با عرض
بنم وما ارد ان اقوله ل انتم ا الاعزا
بنده بوان نحن الحومه وان تلمذ لكم انتم
ايها الشعب
العظم واقول ل
العسر المسلحه في الحرس الثوري
والجيش وقوات التعبئه الابطال وكل قواتنا
العسكريه والى الشعب الايراني العظيم انهم
يعلمون
جيدا وان العدو ايضا يعلم جيدا ان ايران
في هذا
اليوم هي ايران
مقتدر اان صاحب قدرت تو قدرت شده اصبحت
تصنع القوه الحج قاسم سليمان اوصل هذه
البلاد الى مرحله صنع القوه انها مجهزه
متعلمه
متطور از همه مهمر هم من ذلك ان القائد
المفدى وهذا الشعب الايراني العظيم الحاضر
في الساحه دائما هم اهم عناصر القوه في
النظام الاسلامي المقدس في ايران الله ا
[تصفيق]
الله دشمن قدرت جمهور اسلام رو
دهوه اان الاسلام وجربها مرارا و تر اخر
هم
ا ل واطئ ا الشعب الايران العظيم سردار ع
ان التحليل الذي قدمه قائدنا
العزيز السيد حسين السلامي ان العدو دائما
يرى قوه ايران وان العالم جميعا يلاحظ قوه
ايران
المتعاظم فعلم وكونوا مقنين ان المبادره
هي بيد ابء
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
رحم منون نزد نماز جمعه هست و انا و بما
اننا نقترب من صلاه الجمعه محترم مقام
معظم رهب امام جمعه محترم انشال ادن هنا
كلمات سوف
يلق شه عئب القائ المف ولا ند ان ناخذ
وقتا كثيرا من ابناء محافظه كرمان ومن
عوائل واسر الشهداء
العظام الذين جاؤوا ليقدموا التعازي
الحاره للشهداء لذو الشهداء
ولتقم
التبريكات
و المواساه
لابناءه المحافظه الذ خلق
وصنعو سرما نظام
صنعوا المعاجز على طول تاريخهم والذين
كانوا الى جانب النظام الاسلامي المقدس
دائما منذ انطلاقه الثوره الاسلاميه حتى
هذا اليوم وان الله ليبتلي الذين امنوا
وليبتلي المسؤولين الايرانيين وهذه
امتحانات كبيره وصعبه يمر بها الشعب
الايراني
وان الخدمه للشعب الايراني العظيم هي من
جملي ومن بين هذه الامتحانات الربانيه
ويجب علينا ان نسير في هذا الطريق طريق
خدمه الشعب الايراني الذي القي عقين
واعلموا ان هذا
الحضور المؤلف وهذه الجماهير المؤلفه التي
تحتشد
هنا سوف تخيف العدو سوف تلقي الخوف والقلق
في قلوبهم وان
العدو يشعر بالياس
ويشعر
درشه
وقدان بعد هذا الاجرام وهذه العمليه
الجبان التي سقط فيها الابرياء من النساء
والاطفال واننا نعلم جيدا ان نهايه وختام
طوفان الاقصى هي نهايه الكيان
الصهيوني ونهايه
تاريخه
[تصفيق]
و السلام علم و رحمت
الله والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته